hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
I'm going to show you the absolute
fastest way to knock out back pain
within a few minutes so check this out
so what you're going to do is you're not
going to work on the back you're going
to work on the opposite the front part
so let's just pretend that her back pain
is right in the lower part of the right
where her pants comes up that her belt
okay if we draw a line to the front part
but we press on the exact opposite side
your belly button is right here so it's
just below the bed line I press into
this point what's going to happen it's
going to relieve the back over here now
the use of secret the secret is you have
to match
wherever the back pain is just pretend
there's a line going right through her
body okay and sometimes it's like a
broad area in the back so you might want
to go this way in that way and what I
like to do is use a massage to what I'm
doing this myself I would use a massage
tool to press into these spots so what
you're going to do is like sometimes the
pain is over to this side then we just
shift over and we press into it or if
it's on this side you press on this side
what's fascinating it's always going to
be very very very tender on the front
part that's opposing the back part pain
and that's how you know you hit the
right spot what you're going to do is
going to feel around to the epicenter of
where it hurts now I can already feel
this is the spot that's the most tight
on her which is probably the most tender
is it yeah and so I'm going to just
massage this for a little bit less than
30 seconds and all that back pain is
going away now two things going to
happen either the pain is going to go
away and you might have to do this
several times or it's going to keep
coming back in which case that you have
to look deeper into it could be a disc
problem it could be other things but
this is the fastest way to knock out
back pain that I know and by working in
the opposite side no one does this they
work on the back they don't work on the
front all these muscles will melt the
lower back okay so go ahead and try this
and put your comments below